من السياحه الى خدمه العملاء وحتى الصناعه
وخدمات الاموال ومحطات تلفزيون تنفق الصين
مئات الملايين من الدولارات سنويا على
الموظفين الافتراضيين مع تطور الصناعه في
البلاد اصبح انتاج شخصيه ثلاثيه الابعاد
اقل كلفه بنسبه 80% عام 2021 اليوم يكلفوه
تصميم شخص افتراضي نحو اربعه عشر الفا
و300 دولار على الفضاء الالكتروني الصيني
الذي اكتسب المؤثر في شعبيه كبيره خلال
السنوات الاخيره هو بعيد عن الفضاء
الشخصيه لا يتعرف ضريبيا ولا يسير الجدل
هذا ما يؤيده استطلاعه راي حديث توصل الى
ان
45% من المعلنين قد يتوجهون لرعايه مؤثره
افتراضيه او يدعونا شخصيه افتراضيه لتمثيل
علامتهم التجاريه خلال العام الجاري صناعه
شخصيات او البشر الافتراضيه مزدهره وتتضخم
في الصين خبرنا الغريب هو ان من اشهر
الوظائف في المجال الصحفيون والمذيعات
[موسيقى]
محاوله نفهم معك بالشكل المبسط وبطريقه
مبسطه كيف يتم صناعه وبرمجه الاشخاص
الافتراضيه طيب بدايه سهام ونادين هي
عباره هناك عده مثل او عده طرق لصناعه هذه
الدوله الاشخاص اولا يا اما تكون هالكرام
اللي هي الان في كاسات ضوئيه مع الليزر مع
شاشات بحيث يطلع مجسد كامل وكانت هناك
استضافات في دبي اوبراليه عبد الحليم لام
كلثوم ايضا هناك مثلا اللي هي طبعا اللي
هي تكون على شاشه خلق شخصيه افتراضيه همم
هي عباره عن تودي طبعا هذول الاشخاص يتم
همم يعني اذا ما كان في همم بهاينده مثلا
مذيعات تتكلم يعني هيكون في شخص همم في
خلف الكواليس هو يحكي ويتكلم وهي مجرد
صوره انعكاس عنا على شاشه معينه بس في
اللي هي بنت القاء نفسها مثل الروبوتات هي
عباره عن ماشين لان نتعلم
الالاتصال فيهم على البنك وتجنن دائما
تظلها
تعصبنا دائما هي عباره عن مشير لانك تتعلم
انه اذا يسالك كذا جوابك كذا ده يسالك كذا
جواب كذا بروجرامنج وترد عليك ففي اللي
يكون خلفه شخص حقيقي وفي اللي يكون خلفه
مجرد ماشي او تقنيه تعلم الاله ببساطه
طبعا هي المساعده جدا
الصين طب ما انت اصلا عندك كثافه سكانيه
كثير كبيره مليار ونصف المليار نسبه طب
ليه بدهم يستعينوا بموظفين افتراضين في
هالحاله
يمكن هناك وظائف معينه
بتحتاجنا البنك او مثلا السياحه كانوا
مرشد سياحي او مثلا يعني في وظائف معينه
طلب انك تتكلمين نفس الكلام وتشرحين نفس
الشرح وتردين نفس الردود فبالتالي بعد هذه
الوظائف تتطلب هذا النوع من الاشخاص او
هؤلاء الاشخاص الافتراضيين بس اللي يصير
بالصين اليوم ايضا انه هناك يعني الغريب
في الموضوع انه هناك حركه كامله يبنون
بلديه كامله ليه صناعه هؤلاء الاشخاص
الافتراضيين اللي من المفترض ان توصل
لحجمها لهذه الصناعه سبعه مليار دولار بعد
اربع بعد سنتين في الصين يعني هناك توجه
كامل واستثمارات كامله في عده شركات تقنيه
لبناء هؤلاء الاشخاص ويمكن مبدئيا هم
يعملون في فلسطين بس اكيد هم يهون تصديرهم
الى باقي الدول العالم